dos casas reducidas a escombros a
mediados de agosto un ataque de las
fuerzas del frente de liberación popular
de tigre o fl pt asoló esta aldea
dejando a varias personas heridas la
casa de bel hands sigue en pie pero
dentro todo está destruido desde julio
la guerra en tigre se ha trasladado al
suroeste en ampara donde el ejército
federal etíope ha apoyado por grupos
armados locales se enfrentan con las
fuerzas rebeldes de tigre
pero gracias a dios seguimos vivos
en esta casa el tejado y la pintura de
las paredes eran de metal y calidad pero
ahora parece una casa vieja
anuncia votar o llevar un bajón elche
verján estaba tomando café con su mujer
y su padre en esta casa cercana cuando
explotó un proyectil
estamos sentados allí y cuando de
repente una explosión me dieron en la
mano y caí al suelo mi mujer fue
arrojada con twente así yo
estoy muy preocupado temo que el amor de
na golpee pronto porque esta vez pasó
muy cerca
mujeres niños todos en el pueblo usen el
sonido de las alarmas en la distancia en
agosto las fuerzas de la flt ocuparon la
ciudad de nefasta y sus alrededores en
la región central de anjara se les acusa
de saquear infraestructuras y de atacar
a los aliados del gobierno del primer
ministro etíope había met el marido de
esta mujer fue secuestrado por soldados
y nos miembro del partido en el poder y
antiguo soldado del ejército federal
etíope su cuerpo fue encontrado cerca de
un río acababan de encontrar el cuerpo
de mi marido cuando vinieron a mi casa
registrar la teoría afortunadamente
había pensado en esconder el uniforme de
mi marido porque pensé que podrían
mandarme si encontraban esa ropa las
fuerzas tigra llanas se vieron
rápidamente obligadas a retirarse por el
ejército etíope apoyado por las milicias
sámaras
las autoridades afirman que el fl [__]
ha sufrido varias derrotas y ha perdido
territorio en las últimas semanas el
gobierno local de anjara se congratula
de la movilización popular que habría
contribuido a hacer retroceder al fl
estamos bastante seguros de que podemos
eliminar a la flt en un futuro cercano
pero incluso después de radicar el fl pt
tiene región de amara pero también la
región de afar los perseguiremos en
otras partes del país porque el tigre es
parte de etiopía debemos erradicar al fl
desde el diu porque también luchamos por
la libertad del pueblo y no
en delhi prix of the great y punto según
el gobierno regional 500.000 lámparas
han sido desplazadas por los
enfrentamientos
las organizaciones humanitarias
proporcionan ayuda alimentaria pero los
medios son insuficientes aquí en el
norte de la región unas mil personas
acuden cada día a esta campaña de
distribución distribuimos cereales
arvejas partidas para los cereales son
15 kilos para las arvejas partidas son
1,5 kilos
que son 0 45 kilos en este distrito 6
mil beneficiarios son personas
desplazadas ataca situación de seguridad
es mala muchas personas han huido de sus
comunidades y se están refugiando en la
ciudad principal del distrito el
problema es muy grave
la distribución se dirige a las familias
más pobres de la zona la mitad de ellos
son desplazados por el conflicto
valle huyó a pie hace unos días afirma
que las fuerzas del frente de liberación
popular de tigre atacaron y saquearon su
pueblo las ovejas y las gallinas han
desaparecido
también mataron todas nuestras cabras
solo nos quedan las pocas papas que
dejaron
los servimos y las comemos para
sobrevivir sin sal solo con agua hervida
estas provisiones podrán alimentar a
valle y a sus cinco hijos hasta un mes
por ahora no saben cuándo podrán volver
a casa su aldea llena está casi
completamente desierta desde la masacre
que al parecer se cometió allí a
principios de septiembre los cadáveres
siguen cubriendo las carreteras el
número de víctimas del ataque sigue sin
estar claro debajo de estas piedras los
cuerpos eran enterrados apresuradamente
según las pocas personas que quedaban
allí los rebeldes tigre ya nos atacaron
a los civiles mientras subían tras verse
obligados a retirarse asesinatos que
podrían constituir crímenes de guerra
crímenes de los que también se acusa a
los ejércitos etíopes y eritreos en
tigre el fl pp ha negado las acusaciones
dijeron que no nos matarían pero cuando
tuvieron que dar la vuelta y pasar de
nuevo por nuestra aldea fue cuando
masacraron a la gente tres sacerdotes
resultaron heridos y dos de ellos
acabaron juzgar al parecer los
habitantes de la zona fueron
secuestrados durante el ataque algunos
residentes siguen buscando a sus
familiares y temen otro ataque del
frente de liberación popular de tigre
las fuerzas tigra llanas intentan
imponerse a través de las montañas
estratégicas que dominan las principales
ciudades el acceso a sudán a través de
la región de amhara les proporcionaría
una ruta de suministro vital